- My name is Jordan Kepler.
I'm from Santa Ynez, California.
I am a full-time
graphic designer
and a part-time bladesmith.
I do a lot of camping
out of my truck.
Out there, having one knife
that you can chop wood,
make a campfire, prep
dinner and all that stuff
is pretty important.
My name is Jesse Overton.
I'm 28, and I'm from
Medford, Oregon.
I was in the Marine
Corps for four years.
Being in the Marine Corps,
one of the biggest things
that we pride ourselves
on is being able to adapt,
and being flexible.
And I think that
all those things
really are going to make me
prepared for this competition.
GRADY POWELL: Jordan,
Jesse, congratulations.
It is now between the two of you
to figure out who's going home
with the title of "Forged
in Fire" Champion,
and a check for $10,000.
Now, in the final
round of competition,
you guys are going back home
to work on an iconic weapon
from history.
And that weapon is--
the headhunter's ax.
The headhunter ax is
both a tool and a weapon
of the native Igorot tribe,
who hail from the mountains
of the Philippines.
Featuring a sharp
spike on one side that
is used to pierce
shields and armor,
it also contained a
wide, lethal ax head
on the other side designed
to swiftly decapitate
enemies in the heat of battle.
An intimidating
weapon, tribes would
display the heads of
their victims to strike
fear into their enemies.
The legacy of this
deadly ax lives on today,
and can be seen
in the video game,
"State of Decay, Breakdown."
GRADY POWELL: So good luck.
We will see you in three days.
Good luck, man.
JORDAN KEPLER: We're back,
day one at my home forge
here in Santa Ynez, California.
I'm going to be making
a headhunter's ax.
We're getting close to
forge welding temperature.
But this is definitely
a pivotal moment,
to know that my forge welder is
set, and they're really nice,
and it's a homogeneous piece
of steel all the way through.
So this has got to
be perfect right now.
I'm really excited to see that
it is actually forge welded.
Today, the biggest hurdle is
going to be that heat treat.
That's a weird shape.
Let's hope everything goes well.
That thing just doesn't
fit in there very well.
This is a little nerve-racking,
making sure that it's perfectly
heated across the board.
There we go.
[bleep]
We got a definite
warp right here.
I need to run into
my straightening jig,
straighten it, and
let it sit and wait.
Oh man, it's perfectly straight.
Yes!
Only one day left.
We're going to try and get some
pins through here, to make sure
that not only we have a chemical
connection to the blade,
but we have a
mechanical connection.
We're through!
And now, I'm going
to get everything
pretty much to final finish.
That is looking mean!
Yeah, she's sharp.
[laughs]
JESSE OVERTON: I
am back at my home
forge here in Medford, Oregon.
I don't really have any
time to make mistakes.
Kind of my strategy is to
draw out the spike end first.
That's going to be the hardest
and longest thing to draw out.
So I get done forging, and
now, it's time for the quench.
And I'm feeling pretty nervous.
I feel like my guts
are in my throat.
Oh yeah.
We did it!
It's hard!
We're sitting pretty
good for day two.
I'm getting all the final
touches on the ax head.
I really want to make sure that
I get this ax nice and sharp.
I opened up a seam where my
weld met the actual socket.
If I weld on this
for too long, then
it's going to ruin
my heat treat.
I think we got it.
The bladesmithing gods
have looked out for me.
The gap is gone.
So relieved right now.
I was doing a little
bit of research
on the warriors of this tribe.
And I noticed that
there's certain tattoos
that they give warriors
after they behead somebody.
So I'm going to incorporate
some of those designs
into the handle.
That way, it'll give
some good traction,
but also look bad ass.
Nice, thick coat on there.
It's looking really nice.
But I really want to see if
my edge geometry is there.
So I decided to do a cut test.
[laughing]
Oh, I feel so much better!
On round two of my knife,
it did not cut very well.
So to know that I'm
actually able to make
something that can cut, and do
it well, it feels really good.
I'd say it's a pass, in my book.
GRADY POWELL: Gentlemen,
welcome back to the forge.
Both your blades look
absolutely deadly.
But there's really only one
way we can find out if they
are as deadly as they look.
We've got a strength
test, a sharpness test.
And up first, the kill.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
The Igorot headhunter's ax--
a weapon that I've
always fantasized
about, because it's very
close to my Filipino heritage.
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your headhunter's ax will
do, I will take your weapon
and deliver some lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Jordan, are you ready?
Because I am.
I think so.
Let's do this.
JORDAN KEPLER: Right now,
I'm pretty intimidated.
If that spike hits a
backbone, or the skull,
or anything like that, that
thing could snap right off.
[shouting]
DOUG MARCAIDA:
All right, Jordan,
let's talk about your
headhunter's ax here.
Your edges here are very sharp.
With every strike,
it dug in very deep
into this ballistics dummy.
The spike you have here,
even digging into the skull,
did not bend.
It feels good in the hand.
And more importantly,
sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Jesse,
you're up next.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
I'm feeling nervous.
I'm worried about my ax
head flying off the socket,
because those bones are dense.
You know, going into a human
skull is not an easy task.
[shouting]
Ooh, he headbutted me.
All right, Jesse, let's
talk about your headhunter's
ax over here.
First up, the
handle construction.
So we did some research on
some Polynesian tattoos there.
Looks good, and it
feels good in the hand.
Your edges here
penetrated very deep
into this ballistics dummy.
Now, your spike here, not only
did it penetrate the skull,
but it also cut it,
and it stayed true.
Overall, sir, your
headhunter's ax will kill.
Thanks, Doug.
J. NEILSON: All
right, gentlemen,
welcome to our strength test--
the bamboo and skull chop.
Now, you got two totally
different materials here.
You got the springy bamboo that
likes to bounce things back,
and the skulls that
like to break edges.
So we're going to test both ends
and the overall construction
of your headhunter's axes.
Jordan, you're smiling,
so you're up first.
How about that?
Yes, sir.
OK, let's do it.
[shouting]
Jordan, nice job.
Take a breath now.
OK.
J. NEILSON: Now,
everything held up nicely.
Everything's tight, doesn't
look like anything moved.
Your edges are still sharp.
I mean, the fact that you
made this thing light, tough,
and in Damascus in three days--
that's a heck of a feat.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Jesse, how
you feel after seeing that?
Not good.
Not good?
It'll be fine.
JESSE OVERTON: OK.
- Don't worry about it.
[shouting]
Oh!
[exhales deeply]
Last one, man.
J. NEILSON: All right, Jesse.
On the plus side, it
felt great in the hand.
And your edges
held up just fine.
But just-- all the shockwave
from the force of those strikes
split the handle almost in half.
So I'm definitely not going
to be able to continue
testing with this weapon.
Well, Jesse, we absolutely
hate to see that happen.
Phenomenal job on
your blade itself.
But unfortunately, you
had a catastrophic failure
when your handle broke.
And for that reason,
we can no longer
continue testing your weapon.
I'm going to have to ask you
to please leave the forge.
I felt a little heartbroken,
seeing something that I put so
much work into it to be broke.
But I came onto this
competition just
to prove that I can compete with
some of the best bladesmiths
out there.
And I know I've already
accomplished that,
so I still feel like
I'm going home a winner.
Well, Jordan, you
survived the test.
Your blade came out on top.
So congratulations, you are
the "Forged in Fire" Champion.
And there is a
$10,000 check waiting
for you outside that door.
Very well done.
[laughs]
I just won "Forged in Fire."
I don't really know
what to say right now.
Sasquatch is kind of my mascot,
and so I feel like that's
a Sasquatch-worthy ax.